some dreams are destined to be forever
more dreams
it's incredibly unlikely that i will
ever go to space
that i'll ever win a nobel prize or play
warhammer with henry cavill
but a dream that i have had for pretty
much my entire life
has come true and i can finally
tell you about it because after
two years or so of work i have
written a book i cannot begin to tell
you how happy i am to finally talk about
this i have i've
it's been two years of trying to keep
this huge project secret so first things
first i guess
what is the book what's it about well
it's not your typical youtuber book it's
not about me it's not an autobiography
it's not about youtube
it's about the thing that i'm most
passionate about which is
the earth's atmosphere now of course
there have been plenty of books that
have been written about the atmosphere
indirectly there are several behind me
there have been books that have been
written about weather prediction and
books that have been written about
climate change
but what i don't think has been done to
date is a book that explicitly is
about the atmosphere what it is
how it works and how we worked out
how it works because to me at least the
way that people discuss
weather prediction and the way they
discuss climate change you'd barely
think there was any overlap between
those two fields and yet of course
they both evolved out of the same tree
of knowledge of
atmospheric science and i want to really
stress
this is not a new science it's one of
the oldest branches of human knowledge
it goes back thousands of years
and over the course of its life it's
seen phenomenally interesting
individuals
and these fantastic riddles and
mysteries that perplexed people for
centuries
so the book is about the atmosphere but
more than that
something that i try to do on this
youtube channel and something that i
think typifies good science
communication
is to go beyond just the facts to focus
instead on
the methodology on the contextual
information that leads us to
an understanding in other words how we
worked out
how this stuff works so a fair part of
the book is about the
long arcs of history how science and
technology
and socio-economic factors interacted in
the past to bring us to our modern
understanding now if i was a publicist
this is what i tell you that this is the
book for you
if you breathe air which is that's a
large potential customer base but really
you should get this book if yeah you'd
like to learn a bit more about
weather prediction and climate science
and how we arrived at that modern level
of
knowledge but also if you'd like to
learn a bit more about how the big sky
thing above us
works which leads me to the name i
haven't told you the name yet the book
is called firmament the hidden science
of weather climate change and the air
that surrounds us
the reason for this title is that one of
the largest influences on me in this
project was it's right behind me
infinitesimal by amir alexander this is
a book about the historical development
of infinitesimal calculus
and when i read it it had a really big
effect on me partly because
it's one of the best examples of
historical science communication that
i've ever read
but also because of the simplicity of
the title combined with the imagery on
the front
i absolutely love how the two together
hearken back to this early modern
renaissance
concept of natural philosophy and
science as we
know it just starting to form and
so firmament was to me a natural choice
for this project to try and elicit that
same kind of feeling
firmament just being a very old word
originally from latin meaning
the sky and well that's kind of what the
book's about
wait what's that you want a title and
cover
fine okay this is what it's going to
look like
roughly it's nearly there we just need
to finalize it i'm delighted to say that
firmament is available to pre-order i've
just got goosebumps from starting that
sentence
i am delighted to say that firmament is
available to pre-order right now
there'll be a link down there in the
description and it will be out
on january 27th 2022.
i obviously think you should buy a copy
and pre-order one because i think it's a
really interesting book
but to sweeten the deal the lovely
people over at nebula which is the
educational streaming service that i
am on and also have a small role in
running unprompted by me
have said that if you pre-order a copy
and you email proof of purchase to this
email address
down here then they will give you a
month free
on nebula so there you go
added incentive but this is the time
that i now need to ask for your help
because whilst working on this project i
found that
i really like doing this kind of work i
love writing
and i love researching and getting to
really immerse myself
in things that i didn't know very much
about but
learned about from visiting places and
reading books and reading papers
and frankly i'd like to do this again
i have lots of ideas for other projects
that i'd like to write but
i'm not going to get an opportunity to
do those things unless
this book does really well at pre-order
because i'm a first-time author and that
pre-order response is going to send a
really strong signal to the publishers
about how viable this is as well
both as a book but also how viable i am
as an author so i asked the
publishers how many pre-orders did they
think would be a good
target to aim for and they said that 200
pre-orders in the first
week would be really really good so
obviously pre-order the book
if you would like to read it if you
think it sounds interesting but i'd ask
you if you're on the fence
and you'd like to support my work and
you'd like to give me a shot at doing
this again
and really get my kind of authorial
career as silly as that sounds to say
out loud
off the ground it would mean the world
to me
if you could pre-order a copy let's see
if we can
smash that 200 pre-order copies
in a week because i think we can do it
so just to quickly summarize
i've written a book no really i actually
have written a book
it's called firmament it's about the
atmosphere and it's going to be
available
on january 27th 2022 but you can
pre-order a copy right now at the link
in the description
now two things quickly just before i
finish off the video firstly
i'm sure that a lot of you will have
questions about this project that i
haven't answered in this video so i'm
going to be doing a q a live stream
tonight at 7 pm bst
on my twitch channel twitch.tv forward
slash dr simon clark
there is a google form down there in the
description lots of links in the
description today there is a link down
there in the description to a google
form where you can ask your questions
and we'll get through as many of them as
we can in the two hours that we have
booked in to do q a
incidentally if you didn't already know
i have a twitch channel where i
do some climate coding and study with me
streams and play video games and paint
warhammer
it's quite a mixed bag and secondly and
far more importantly
i want to say a huge thank you
to every single person who has supported
my work here on youtube
whether that's subscribing or watching
the videos or buying merch or supporting
me on patreon whatever it's been
thank you because if it wasn't for you
people
i wouldn't have this privilege this
opportunity
to to write a book and from
the bottom of my heart thank you so much
because you've made a childhood dream
come true
i i i don't know what to say other than
thank you thank you for believing in me
that's all for this video do join me on
twitch this evening
if you have some questions or if you'd
just like to learn more about the
project
and there will be more videos coming out
in the coming months sort of leading up
to the book's release where i'm
going to talk about the process of
writing it and researching and
also some stories that i didn't quite
have the
words space in the book to actually tell
in full but
i think deserve a youtube video on their
own but thank you so much for watching
again please do pre-order the book if
you'd like to read it of course or if
you'd like to support my ongoing work
down there in the description and
thank you i've said thank you so many
times but thank you again
i'll see you in the next one i'm gonna
be an author